en quoi consiste ce travail de
dévoilement il consiste à mettre au jour
des choses que d'une certaine façon tout
le monde sait mais à un niveau de
profondeur où on ne va plus chercher
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas les
missions qui parle de livres qui parlent
de sciences humaines pour cet épisode un
peu particulier on va pas comme
d'habitude s'intéresser à un livre et un
auteur mais plutôt comme vous avez pu le
voir dans le titre à dix grands courants
de la sociologie contemporaine
bon évidemment chaque courant et chaque
auteur dont on va parler là mériteraient
un épisode monde entier mais en fait je
trouvais ça intéressant de faire un
espèce de récapitulatif des grands
concepts de la sociologie contemporaine
l'histoire que quand moi ou un autre
vous évoquera ses concepts ou quand vous
entendrez parler avec ces termes là
comme interactions nisme symbolique
comme des terrains peu un peu alambiqué
comme ça vous allez en mesure de
comprendre les grandes lignes de ce qui
se cache derrière son courant un cours
en sociologie peut se considérer sous
deux aspects d'un côté la proche et de
l'autre la méthode la proche peut se
comparer à une philosophie une vision
que l'auteur va avoir de la société cela
va déterminer la façon dont il va
concevoir l'individu ses choix et la
façon dont se font et se défont les
groupes sociaux la méthode va quant à
elle déterminer les outils de la
sociologie va prendre dans son sac pour
argumenter sa vision de la société
la méthode est donc contrainte par la
proche on va pas utiliser le même outil
pour voit la situation sous un angle
différent
donc on va parler des courants dans ce
que l'on appelle la sociologie
contemporaine donc en opposition à ce
qu'on appelle la sociologie classique
nécessairement plus anciennes ont fait
cette différence car on considère qu'au
tournant à peu près des années 70
notamment avec la généralisation des
médias de masse et les nouveaux
phénomènes de consommation
on va assister un changement de société
et qui dit changement de société dit
forcément nouveaux courants de pensée
pour la comprendre
cette distinction fait débat et on
pourra y revenir mais pour cet épisode
particulièrement on va partir de ce
principe pour s'intéresser aux auteurs
qui ont participé à l'émergence et l
élaboration de cette sociologie
contemporaine
donc comme je vous le disais la
frontière entre sociologie classique et
sociologie contemporaine elle est assez
discutable que ce soit d'un point de vue
philosophique
nos logiques le courant qui est emmenée
par norbert elias est assez
représentatif de cette transition assez
floue puisque pas mal de ces travaux ont
été publiés avant les années soixante
dix et pourtant pour beaucoup en fait il
est celui qui a enclenché cette
transition entre une sociologie
classique et une sociologie
contemporaine et donc en quoi on va
estimer qui va enclencher cette
transition en fait il va remettre en
cause une opposition qui est
prédominante dans la sociologie
classique c'est holisme contre
individualisme l'individualisme
correspond à une approche ascendante du
social c'est à dire que l'on part des
actions des individus pour pouvoir
comprendre les phénomènes collectifs
l'eau l'isthme quant à lui est une
approche descendante qui par des
propriétés du collectif pour comprendre
les individus pour dépasser cette
opposition que norbert elias jeu stérile
il va utiliser ce qu'on appelle la
théorie des configurations c'est à dire
qu'il estime que l'individu il va
posséder une identité propre
puis celui-ci va s'insérer dans un
milieu qui implique déjà avant son
arrivée des valeurs et des modes de
comportement de cette relation va donc
mettre des configurations qui vont
déterminer les pratiques et les façons
de penser de l'individu dans son livre
qui s'appelle sur le processus de la
civilisation
il estime qu'à mesure que la société
s'étend et se complexifier l'individu va
devoir emmagasiné toujours plus d'une
notion de coordination et d'autocontrôle
vis-à-vis de son milieu il s'agit
notamment du contrôle de la violence qui
est une notion qui est très importante
chez norbert elias et il estime que à
mesure que la société évolue on assiste
un contrôle toujours plus important de
cette violence c'est notamment une
notion qu'il va extraire de l'exemple
des joutes au moyen-âge
au début les joutes n'était régulés que
par un nombre très réduit de règles mais
à force de voir les nobles de la cour se
faire décapiter ou faire des pommes
grosse hémorragie devant leurs yeux les
législateurs de l'époque se sont dit que
ce serait peut-être une bonne idée de
mettre des règles là dedans pour éviter
les bains de sang qui coûte à chaque
fois très très cher au royaume aussi des
règles vont émerger pour contraindre les
pratiques ces règles vont être au fur et
à mesure intériorisée par les
participants pour au final créer une
configuration sociale dans laquelle la
violence est moins prêts
quand dans ce même livre il va
d'ailleurs dire que la société mais pas
seulement un facteur de catégorisation
et d'uniformisation mais aussi à un
processus d'individualisation c'est à
dire que le mélange qui va émerger de
l'individu avec sa propre personnalité
et le milieu avec ses propriétés va
faire émerger une configuration qui est
tout à fait singulière qui est unique
[Applaudissements]
donc l'analyse stratégique comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est l'idée que l'on va
pouvoir regarder le comportement et les
postures des acteurs comme des
stratégies individuelles on va donc
essayer d'expliquer les règles du jeu
social à partir du jeu des acteurs
en fait c'est comme si on regardait des
gens jouer un jeu de société et que de
par leur comportement on essayait de
comprendre les règles du jeu sauf que
dans le social à la différence du de
sociétés ce sont les acteurs qui vont
contribuer à construire les règles du
jeu pour comprendre les auteurs
imaginons un jeu stratégies auxquelles
on enlève quasiment toutes ces règles
dans cet exemple on va partir du
principe que l'objectif des deux joueurs
est à la fois de se divertir et de
vaincre son adversaire
ici le but du jeu c'est capturer les
territoires pour capturer un territoire
il faut que l'attaquant face un nombre
aude est supérieur à celui du défenseur
le nombre utilisable 2d correspondant au
nombre de troupes présents sur un
territoire
si les règles s'arrête là je vais
choisir logiquement de mettre toutes mes
troupes sur un territoire
je suis quasiment sûr dès lors de faire
plus haut dès que mon adversaire
face à cette stratégie donc la logique
de l'adversaire va être de se comporter
de la même manière si malgré cette
réponse à cette stratégie le défenseur
fait toujours un nombre inférieur à
celui de l'attaquant il peut alors
choisir s'il veut de relancer les dés
jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse un score
supérieur à celle de l'attaquant
à ce stade on peut observer deux choses
donc premièrement que les acteurs sont
menées par ce qu'on appelle une
rationalité motivé c'est à dire je veux
gagner donc du coup je choisi cette
stratégie
oui yes needs now touring et des
ingénieurs
deuxièmement on constate que
les décisions d'un acteur peuvent être
conditionnée par les actions les
positionnements d'un autre donc là on ne
pense qu'à lazer une choisi cette
stratégie donc du coup je m'adapte en
choisissant cette autre stratégie
le problème ici c'est qu'on voit bien
que tout cela va tourner assez vite en
rond que la partie risque de ne jamais
finir et que ça va vite sous les tous
les joueurs au sein de la partie les
deux joueurs peuvent donc s'accorder sur
le fait que peu importe le nombre de
troupes
il n'est pas possible d'utiliser plus de
3d et que cd ne peuvent être tiré qu'une
fois
dès lors l'intérêt de placer toutes ses
troupes au même endroit est bien moindre
et des stratégies plus complexes et donc
potentiellement plus intéressante pour
les joueurs peuvent se développer pour
pouvoir ne pas être confrontés au même
problème à la partie suivante cette
règle peut donc être instaurée
définitivement pour rendre les parties
plus intéressante aussi une règle qui
s'applique à tous les joueurs va naître
de l'interaction entre les différents
acteurs
dès lors si un nouveau joueur arrive
dans la partie il va devoir adapter sa
rationalité et donc sa stratégie à cet
ensemble de règles
[Applaudissements]
bon évidemment on n'a pas attendu
berneau pour essayer de comprendre
comment fonctionnent les organisations
ce qu'il apporte de nouveau c'est que il
va essayer de démontrer l'importance de
tes relations entre les acteurs dans la
structuration des organisations ce que
va dire l'auteur sait que des
déterminants tels que l'âge le sexe le
caractère son propre à l'individu est
que ces éléments vont inciter à agir
d'une certaine manière
seulement ces facteurs ne sont pas
suffisants pour expliquer l'ensemble de
ses agissements
en cela il va dire que ces facteurs vont
entraîner une motivation à agir qui va
s'activer en fonction des opportunités
que celui ci va observer au sein de
l'organisation
dans une entreprise il existe donc des
stratégies d'action motivée par des
rationalités individuel ces stratégies
rentrer en interaction entre elles et
avec la stratégie globale de
l'organisation
les tensions qui vont exister entre ces
volontés à agir on s'influence et entre
elles pour produire des actions
individuelles des actions de groupe et
des modifications dans la dynamique de
l'organisation on voit donc bien que la
sociologie des organisations est à la
fois une analyse des ancrages de
l'organisation dans un espace social
mais également son évolution au regard
de la rencontre des stratégies d'
individus qui la composent
parce que au delà de sa stratégie
personnelle il ya aussi toutes les
stratégies et toutes les rationalités
des individus qui font partie des sept
organisations là mais également bern ots
a souligné
la présence d'une stratégie qui est
propre à l'organisation du cool individu
va avoir pour but de faire coïncider de
faire rentrer en adéquation sa propre
stratégie et les dynamiques qui sont
présentes dans l'organisation donc aux
origines de la pensée de bourdieu il y a
le constat qu' il y à une asymétrie de
distribution entre les différents
individus au sein du social dit un peu
plus clairement on ne naît pas tous
égaux au sein d'une société
pierrot est ce que tu es pas en train
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes là on
n'est pas tous égaux à merci d'accord
donc au delà de ça il va essayer de
comprendre le mécanisme qui fait que les
individus peuvent considérer cette
asymétrie comme légitime pour affirmer
cela il passe notamment par le concept
de l'habitus qui est un concept que j'ai
abordé dans une précédente vidéo que
jamais prêt évidemment dans la
description pour caricaturer l'homme
riches et éduquées a potentiellement
aussi une meilleure éducation a été
sensibilisée à plus d'oeuvres
culturelles a obtenu une meilleure
alimentation a eu l'occasion de
participer à des activités plus
diversifiée que l'homme issu d'une
famille précaires et moins éduqué cela
entraîne nécessairement une meilleure
aptitude au social pour le premier
seulement
plutôt que de considérer que cet
avantage est issu de son milieu il va
développer avec ses pairs une croyance
que ces qualités sont naturelles et donc
elle légitime
l'ascendance de ces individus sur les
classes sociales moins favorisés et donc
possédant moins d'atouts sociaux il ya
une sorte de confusion entre l'inné et
l'acquis
on perçoit aussi ce discours de l'autre
côté du spectre social avec des
individus en précarité qui vont pourtant
défendre les grandes fortunes parce
qu'ils voient en eux des qualités qui
justifie cette position dans le social
[Applaudissements]
l'homme pluriel de bernard lahire c'est
une notion qui est construit par nos
positions cette opposition elle se
dresse contre une vision binaire de la
sociologie classique entre d'une part la
socialisation primaire et la
socialisation secondaire d'une part la
primaire qui se dessine pendant
l'enfance par les parents l'école
principalement et de l'autre une
socialisation secondaire se déroulant
vers la fin de l'adolescence et
entretenus par les études la vie
professionnelle les groupes de pairs les
activités extra professionnelles etc
or bernard lahire et annonce qu'il ne
faut pas se limiter à cette vision mais
avance plutôt l'hypothèse d'une
évolution pluriel de l'individu pour
former un habitus complexe cette
complexification va notamment augmenter
avec la prolifération du numérique et
les nouvelles formes de consumérisme
des changements qui vont être en mesure
de remettre en question les
socialisation primaires et secondaires
pour produire des individus pouvant se
détacher de leur habitus initial ainsi
on observe que au delà de la
socialisation primaire et secondaire
les nouvelles formes de communication et
la circulation facilitée des pratiques
va entraîner une altération de l'habitus
il participe ainsi à une vision un peu
plus atomisé du social que la vision
extrêmement déterministe de bourdieu sur
les différentes classes sociales et leur
espace et leurs pratiques au sein de la
société par exemple au sein d'une
famille l'auteur et non ce que on ne
saurait parler d'un habitus familial
mais d'une multiplicité de socialisation
possible par la famille conduisant à des
dispositions pouvoir entrer en
contradiction entre elles donc le
constat de la haye est relativement
radical pour la sociologie
cela implique qu'il est impossible de
prédire les actions ou les pratiques
d'un individu en fonction d'une
socialisation primaire puis secondaires
du coup il va dire que chaque
généralisation automatique que l'on va
faire à partir d'une condition sociale
va entraîner des angles morts sur les
champs sociaux et donc une vision moins
fine des pratiques et des
positionnement des individus comme on a
pu voir avec les auteurs précédent une
des grandes questions la sociologie sait
dans quelle mesure les agents vont
influencer les organisations et de
quelle façon les organisations vont
influencer les agents c'est à dire à la
fois à leur positionnement et leur
comportement pour expliciter ça on peut
se poser la question le fait que la
france soit aujourd'hui une république
sous un régime démocratique
est ce dû au fait que tous les individus
au fil du temps et des mouvements
sociaux ont mis leur volonté d'agir pour
aboutir aujourd'hui à ce fonctionnement
ou est ce que ce sont les structures
antérieures qui ont déterminé
l'évolution de la société française vers
ce modèle en particulier
on comprend bien que l'on peut pas
aboutir à une réponse résumant à juste
l'un ou juste l'autre donc pour
prétendre réseau dans ce clivage anthony
giddens va proposer la théorie de la
structuration celle ci revient à
suggérer qu'il n'est pas pertinent
d'accorder une valeur plus importante à
la structure ou aux agents aussi si on
regarde le fonctionnement d'une
entreprise
la théorie de la structuration va
considérer les deux éléments
l'institution tout d'abord les règles de
l'entreprise sa hiérarchie la
concurrence dans laquelle elle évolue
son domaine d'activité et ses agents
avec leurs profils sociaux leur
comportement lors des interactions leur
rapport aux valeurs de l'institution
guide n va impliquer par sa théorie
qu'il n'existe pas un élément plus
important que l'autre mais c'est en
traitant sans hiérarchie les activités
de l'individu sur l'institution et les
fondements de l'institution elle même
que la sociologie sera capable de
comprendre la dynamique de l'entreprise
et de ses agents
[Applaudissements]
donc ce courant a la particularité des
marges et principalement de la
psychologie
bon c'est un concept un peu raide et un
peu denses du coup on va essayer d'y
aller un peu progressivement georges et
berthe mines s'intéresse énormément
domaine de la psychologie et il veut
rentrer en rupture avec les deux grands
courants de la psychologie de l'époque
c'est à dire d'un côté le behaviorisme
et l'autre côté la psychanalyse
je vais essayer de définir ces deux
courants assez rapidement je risque de
me faire insulter par les gens qui
connaissent très bien le sujet et c'est
juste pour que vous ayez un petit un
petit aperçu de ce que ça implique pour
faire simple le behaviorisme plus
explicite et notamment par l'exemple de
l'histoire du chien de pavlov donc
pavlov mais un chien dans une cage
déclenche une sonnerie
puis après cette sonnerie libère
quelques friandises il répète
l'opération un bon nombre de fois puis
va déclencher la sonnerie cenc des
friandises n'atterrisse dans la cage du
chien on constate alors que le chien
salivait comme si la sonnerie seul
l'avait mis en appétit et qu'il
attendait donc les friandises de cette
même sonnerie aussi le behaviorisme
c'est une approche sur laquelle on
développe nos réponses en fonction d'un
stimulus donc évidemment pas bluff a
fait son effet sur les chiens on a aussi
un tas d'expériences qui prouve que ça
marche très très bien
si avec les humains et là par exemple si
jamais ce sont là où ce sont là autant
de chances que pour le premier son vous
aviez voulu regarder entièrement dans
vos poches ou que le deuxième selon vous
évoquez netflix ou le fait de regarder
une série ou un film
la psychanalyse est une approche qui ne
se fonde pas sur une approche de
stimulus réponse mais par une méthode
d'investigation verbal des processus
mentaux
ce processus a pour but initial de
soigner et va également mener à
l'émergence de concepts plus globaux de
compréhension de la pensée humaine
notamment avec de grandes figures que
vous connaissez peut-être tels que freud
jung ou lacan bref ça c'est des deux
grands courants au moment où me va
débarquer il va choisir
concevoir les choses autrement il va
créer l'hypothèse que la compréhension
des phénomènes qui nous entoure
qu'ils soient subjectif ou objectif
découle forcément d'une interprétation
personnelle
ce qui veut donc dire que peu importe
l'événement la victoire d'une équipe de
sport par exemple l'élection d'un
candidat politique ou un désastre
sanitaire
ce n'est pas tant le fait qui va
conditionner la réaction de l'individu
que son rapport aux faits deuxièmement
il va également dire que le cadre dans
lequel nous comprenons va dépendre des
interactions que le haut par entretenir
avec autrui c'est dans l'altérité que
nous construisons notre rapport au monde
et à nous mêmes qu'on bordel de merde
c'est hyper beau c'est hyper beau qu'est
ce que cela implique pour ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui à savoir la
sociologie
cela veut dire que lorsque l'on
interagit verbalement ou non verbalement
avec les autres individus on échange des
symboles c'est à dire des
représentations du monde des
représentations du réel
c'est dans cet échange de symboles que
l'on va non seulement comprendre qui
nous entourent mais également nous
identifier au sein d'un groupe où juste
rupture aussi l'interactionnisme
symbolique a pour objet non seulement
d'expliquer la façon dont on construit
une représentation mais également la
façon dont se structure en tant que
société à partir de ces représentations
rappelons que pour qu'une société existe
les membres de cette société doivent
nécessairement partagée des
représentations et des symboliques en
commun
[Applaudissements]
mon gars klinger pas de blague garfinkel
ce qu'il affectionne par-dessus tout
c'est l'étude du terme et en
l'occurrence il veut se démarquer des
autres courants la sociologie en
étudiant non pas les grands événements
les grandes organisations et les grands
phénomènes de la société mais plutôt les
pratiques et les activités quotidiennes
ou rituels de nos sociétés comme son nom
l'indiqué cette technique est issu de
l'ethnologie donc l'étude des sociétés
traditionnelles qu'auparavant on
appelait sociétés primitives
la particularité de cette approche est
qu'elle s'intéresse justement surtout
aux pratiques spécifiques
quelles sont les règles des sports
pratiqués par les mapuche au chili ou
quels sont les rituels autour de la
cuisine pratiqué par les cinq miss en
norvège
ces méthodes d'analysé sont
principalement basées sur l'analyse
conversationnelle c'est-à-dire l'étude
des interactions notamment verbal entre
les individus d'un même groupe
ce qui le dit donc c'est que c'est avec
cette analyse d activité anodine que
l'on va réaliser une analyse film de ce
qui fait société dont garfinkel il dit
que cette analyse elle n'est pas
réservée aux groupes autochtones et
qu'il est intéressant également de
l'appliquer à nos sociétés occidentales
ou des notions principales articule son
courant l'un des xi qualité et la
réflexivité l'intoxication et c'est une
propriété d'un mot d'un geste ou d'un
symbole qui implique que ceux ci ne se
comprennent correctement que dans le
contexte où ils ont été utilisés aussi
en changeant de contexte on va changer
de sens bonjour je nouvelle aise
bienvenue au centre médico social
bonjour je nous fais pas bienvenue à le
bit fait plaisir bonjour monsieur moment
derrière suspect feriez-vous parti de la
haine je suis démasqué pour garfinkel
c'est un des xi qualité est déterminante
car si on a besoin du contexte pour
comprendre alors on peut se servir des
mots pour comprendre le contexte le
deuxième concept donc essayer de la
réflexivité il peut assez facilement se
croiser voir se confondre avec le
premier donc on va essayer de se baser
sur notre exemple précédent
la réflexivité en est aux méthodologies
c'est la représentation que va faire
naître un signe pour un individu en
fonction de son historique et de son
contexte
bonjour monsieur je suis un agent de la
gestapo
vous êtes là espoir mais secrète vous
êtes un terroriste dangereux je suis
encore parce qu il
bonjour vous êtes aussi résistant
gestion ont fait partie de l'armée
secrète c'est ça ça fait plaisir de
rencontrer une personne comme vous
courageuse prête à tout pour libérer du
joug de cet affreux dictateur
ça fait plaisir
comme on le voit dans cet exemple avec
ses acteurs les deux individus
perçoivent le même signe avec la même
signification mais ils n'ont pas la même
représentation pour prendre un exemple
un peu moins radical
lorsque je vois un clavier avec 88
touches noires et blanches cela va mener
ses serments me renvoyer au concept de
piano cependant si l'on joue tous les
jours cela va mais bloquer un objet
familier et potentiellement agréable si
on m'a obligé à jouer petit et gray
arrêté depuis
ça peut me renvoyer à la frustration et
à de mauvais souvenirs et si j'en ai
jamais joué cela va plutôt évoqué un
objet de décoration ou les coudes de
quelqu'un d'autre que moi
dans tous ces cas de figure pourtant je
me réfère bien au concept de piano même
objet même signification mais
représentation totalement différente par
rapport à celui ci
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être différemment des
courants précédent il s'agit pas ici
quand on parle de sujets pragmatique
d'un mouvement unifié mais plutôt de la
réunion de différents courants
sociologiques
c'est une sociologie qui émergent à la
fin des années 80 et elle va regrouper
notamment d'entrée à s'inspirer
notamment de l'ethno méthodologie dont
convient d'évoquer de la sociologie des
sciences mais également de la sociologie
des formes de protestation cette
approche se conçoit dans le but je cite
de construire une approche qui tient
compte de la capacité des acteurs à
s'ajuster à différentes situations de la
vie sociale donc pour expliciter cela on
va se référer donc aux cinq points qui
sont mentionnés dans l'article wikipédia
qui est relative à son cours wicked
pictures wikipédiens je fais un tacle le
mec est mieux que moi je vais pas
commencer à dire des trucs moins
intéressants sous prétexte que ça fait
pas plaisir on dépasse l'opposition
entre police mais individualisme c'est à
dire entre le groupe et l'individu on
prend acte que le concept de classe
sociale a explosé et on essaye donc de
construire des outils d'analysé qui
prennent en compte le fait qu'il existe
une foultitude de mode d'engagement
c'est à dire d'attitude de comportement
ou d'interactions au sein du social on
ne se met pas dans une logique de
rupture absolue avec le sens commun
c'est à dire que l'on va pas essayer de
confronter un individu un questionnement
binaire venant de l'extérieur mais on va
plutôt via la méthode de l'enquète
essayer de créer un cadre de
compréhension en relation directe avec
son milieu et ses modes de
représentations on récuse l'idée d'un
vision rationnelle et uniformes pour le
considérer comme une personne portant en
elle une multitude de singularité
variant selon les multitudes de contexte
laurence thévenot qui est également une
figure forte de ce mouvement pas parler
de personnalités à tiroirs un regard qui
partage la vision de l'aïr et son homme
pluriel que nous avons vu juste un petit
peu plus haut enfin on tombe de dépasser
l'opposition entre vision micro et
vision macro en s'intéressant au
processus de formation des collectifs et
des mobilisations plus clairement
on cherche à effacer la frontière entre
les petits groupes et les grands groupes
d'individus en analysant ce qui fait que
l'on passe de l'un à l'autre
cette approche en tant que synthèse de
nouveau
courant elle va vraiment marqué la
sociologie contemporaine on va même
parlé d'un tournant pragmatique en cela
que ça va inspirer un bon nombre
d'auteurs ce qui fait qu'on parle pas de
temps du courant pragmatique et plutôt
des différentes approches pragmatiques
qui ont émergé à partir de ce moment là
[Applaudissements]
pour ce dernier courant on va parler
donc de la théorie de l'acteur réseau de
bruno latour qui va en fait pas mal
s'inspirer de la philosophie de guider
dans la mesure où il va y avoir une
conception symétrique du social
symétrique c'est-à-dire qu'elle
considère que tous aident égale
importance
les facteurs organisationnels cognitif
discursif ou plus généralement les
entités non humaine ça peut être les
objets la technologie les animaux etc
aussi on va dire que tous ces éléments
vont former un réseau qui va permettre
de structurer le social donc pour
expliquer ça on va essayer de prendre
l'exemple de deux personnes qui ce match
surtout nda pour que les deux personnes
ce match donc sur tender il est
nécessaire que les deux et télécharger
l'application qu'ils possèdent un
téléphone compatible que leur historique
personnel et leurs représentations les
amène à chercher un potentiel partenaire
sur cette plateforme que leurs critères
lorsqu'ils se sont inscrits puissent eux
correspond que l'algorithme fasse
apparaître le profil de l'autre sur leur
application et enfin que l'image et le
texte correspondant à chaque profil puis
suscité l'intérêt est donc l'engagement
chez les futurs amoureux du coup comme
on peut le voir c'est donc le réseau
d'interactions entre les différents
éléments qu'il dépend des individus ou
des objets ou des deux qui vont
entraîner la situation sociale si un
élément est absent alors la situation
sera altérée évidemment cette
affirmation est vrai lorsqu'on se réfère
à un médium tel qu'une application de
rencontre mais ça l'est aussi dans
toutes les situations groupes et
mouvements compris dans le social je
développe pas plus cette approche là
pour l'instant
marc est que c'est très grandes lignes
parce que j'aimerais bien parler dans
une très prochaine vidéo
on va donc pour cette très longue vidéo
j'ai bien conscience comme je les dis
juste au début de la vidéo que chaque
courant mériterait en lui-même une vidéo
ce sera peut-être le cas ce serait cool
j'espère simplement que cet épisode nous
a permis de mieux comprendre des
concepts quand vous avez peut-être déjà
évoqués çà ou là ou que vous connaissez
pas ou que c'est à susciter votre
curiosité à vous intéresser à tel ou tel
auteur si vous souhaitez un épisode qui
cette fois-ci s'intéressera plus aux
grands auteurs et aux grands courants de
la sociologie classique
n'hésitez pas à le demander en
commentaire si c'est le cas je me ferai
un plaisir de vous d'essayer de faire
quelque chose de bien sur ce set
historique de la sociologie en remontant
jusqu'aux fondements de ces disciplines
sociologie
n'hésitez pas également à vous abonner à
activer la cloche si vous voulez avoir
des notifications quand je sors inviter
autant que j'en sors pas non plus des
millions par mois normalement vous
devriez pas être hyper hyper dérangé par
la notification
en attendant c'est une superbe journée
soirée et nuit tout ce que vous voulez
et andy à la prochaine salut qu'à sa
mort du malade un grand vide non j'étais
en train de regarder l'émission d'un
examen
[Musique]
vous devez traverser une courage à jour